welcome to official SAT practice Khan
Academy in the College Board have teamed
up to create the only SAT practice tool
developed with the experts who write the
SAT it's personalized for each student
available anytime anywhere and
completely free will create personalized
practice recommendations for you based
on your test results from the PSAT 8/9
PSAT 10 psat/nmsqt and SAT if you
haven't already taken a college board
test you can take our short diagnostic
quizzes to get started your practice
plan will show you where you already
excel and where you should focus your
practice will also create a practice
schedule for you based on your test date
we have tons of interactive practice
questions developed with the College
Board's that give you instant feedback
on your answers as well as hints and
videos to help you master your skills
many sections help you practice under
time pressure we have official practice
tests written by the College Board
taking at least two practice tests will
help you build the experience and
endurance necessary to do well on test
day join more than 1 million students
already using official SAT practice Khan
Academy was probably the best way that I
can use the study my math was below par
using Khan Academy I built it up it
improved my sports traumatically I like
the levelling up it kind of makes it a
game I feel excited and prepared because
it's something that I've already seen
I'm already cut through it so when I
take on the dualist sign up and get
started today at SAT practice org